Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Wo würdest du dich eigentlich verstecken, wenn du dich verstecken müsstest?
Das könnte ich ja jetzt nicht sagen.
Ach komm, sag mal.
Ähm in einem Flughafen und einem großen Transitbereich.
Ja, Leute verstecken sich, wir verstecken uns nicht. Wir sind äh nach wie vor nackt im Internet und äh geben unsere Stimmbandprobenpreis. Nicht wahr?
Ähm spätestens wenn wir aufgehört haben, die Tasse zu drücken,
Und blicken auf eine Welt in Aufruhr. Hatten wir ja letztes Jahr im Prinzip,
letztes Mal in der achtundsechzig auch schon,
angesprochen, da war dann aber auch noch nicht so ganz absehbar wie weit das so trägt,
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hatten wir letztes Mal nur diesen Aspekt,
Äh auf der Liste mit dem Herrn Snoden und mittlerweile ist ja äh auch noch was ganz anderes. In den Fokus gerückt, nämlich vor allem seine dramatische Flucht,
Ja, zwei, ja, der nächste der nächste Whistleblower irgendwie auf dem Versuch, sich äh den Autoritäten zu entziehen,
Schwer einzuschätzen, dass jetzt der der Boulevardteil, ne, hiervon.
Wir wissen den Boulevard, den müssen wir natürlich an den Anfang legen, um um Hörer zu gewinnen. Und Hörerinnen. Also ähm.
Von den Konkurrenzpodcast überschalten.
Zum letzten oder letzter Stand war ja, dass er in Hongkong irgendwo saß. Ne, man wusste nicht genau, wo in Hongkong.
In irgendeinem Hotel oder auch woanders.
In irgendeinem Hotel. Und dann ähm
von diesem Hotel telefoniert ja dann äh eifrig hin und her und äh es begab sich dann, dass dass die USA einen ähm Haftbefehl ausgestellt haben und äh von äh Hongkong dann die Auslieferung verlangt haben. Haben also,
gesagt, ey, wir wollen den haben. Und relativ äh ungefähr zu dieser Zeit ähm rannte er irgendwie aus seinem Hotel raus, Richtung Flughafen und liegt ähm,
so unterwegs noch, dass die USA chinesische Mobilfunkanbietern Netze und Glasfaserbetreiber irgendwie hacken. Das heißt, er hat den äh,
den Chinesen noch kurz äh als als Abschiedsgeschenk die Information dagelassen. Übrigens natürlich die USA greift noch euch äh auch an,
und sie sie erzählen nicht nur, dass ihr sie die ganze Zeit angreift, was ihr natürlich auch macht, sondern sie greifen euch auch an, aber dann wisst ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon, ja, also.
Prompt wurde er auch gefeiert in den Staatsmedien, was dann doch äh er für ein toller Typ sei. So schleimig, so eklig, ja wenn man sich das mal im Detail anschaut, aber er hat natürlich einen gewissen Unterhaltungswert.
Es hat einen Unterhaltungswert und äh als Dankeschön für diesen Unterhaltungswert äh sagte dann äh China äh.
Lasst doch andere äh sozusagen dieses Problem haben. Warum müssen wir uns das jetzt hier eigentlich eintreten?
Genau, jetzt hat er aber zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Was sehr interessant ist, weil, ich glaube, da haben wir auch das letzte Mal nur drüber spekuliert, aber Hongkong hat ja tatsächlich ein Auslieferungsabkommen mit den USA. Und das haben sie dann, das haben sie ja auch bekommen, also dieses, diesen Auslieferungsantrag,
hätte Form Fehler wäre nicht so richtig begründet.
Weißt du, was der Vorfehler war? Der Vorfehler war ganz cool. Also war ein Formfehler drin.
Ja, was denn?
Sie wollten einen Edward Jay Snowden haben. Ja aber wofür steht denn das J, also heißt das jetzt? James, Jim, Jerome.
Ernsthaft?
Wir können jetzt nicht hier irgendjemand ey hier ist China, die heißen ja alle Edward Stone, ja.
Ja, wir haben hier ein größeres größere Sammlung.
So und sie hätten ihn also es war schon so ein bisschen spät zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte er ja, wenn ich das jetzt recht erinnere, hatten die USA ja seinen Pass auch schon revotet,
Das heißt, das war jetzt so ein bisschen es ist auf jeden Fall mit diesem mit diesem äh Revoke Pass, also mit diesem,
ungültigen Pass. Ähm das finde ich jetzt sowieso nochmal ganz spannend. Das wird gleich, wird gleich nochmal auch äh auch interessant. Auf jeden Fall.
Aber du darfst jeden Jahr ausreisen lassen aus deinem Land. Also das ist ja sozusagen also ausreisen lassen ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht wenn nichts gegen dich vorliegt,
ja. Da hatten sie ja keine akkuraten Informationen. Dann können sie ja sagen, ja, geht doch.
Gut, gut, dass du weg bist.
Uhr egal. Na ja, gut, dass du weg bist. Und dann saß er in einem Flugzeug, vermutlich also ich meine, gesehen hat ihn noch keiner. Es hat ihn auch niemand auf diesem Flugzeug gesehen. Also.
Auf dem Flug nach.
Ja, also soweit ich das gelesen habe, haben ja die Reporter dann, also erst dann nach Moskau, also geflogen, vermutlich, ja.
Ganz kurz, also China sagt dieses Ausweisegesuch äh aus äh dieses Auslieferungsgesuch wegen diesem Pipapo. Der Typ ist bei uns rausgegangen. Er steigt in ein Flugzeug und so so will es die Legende, fliegt nach Moskau.
Ähm Moskau allerdings also er, er beginnt die Welttournee der Feinde der USA, ja also zu dem Zeitpunkt war die Gerüchtelage, er möchte jetzt fliegen von China nach Moskau, über Venezuela, na äh.
Kuh Kuba. Er ist Puba.
Über über Kuba nach Venezuela, ja? So das Einzige, es hätte jetzt noch so.
Dann in Äquator zu landen.
Aber vorher wahrscheinlich noch Nordkorea,
der Iran, ja?
Er hat leider, ich da gibt's ja jetzt viel. Das ist vielleicht ein Punkt, da muss man kurz was zu sagen. PR-mäßig ist das natürlich jetzt nicht besonders günstig.
Für ihn in den USA.
Für ihn in den USA, wenn er äh jetzt äh ausgerechnet in diese Länder fliegt. Andererseits ist es natürlich auch klar, dass nur diese Länder bereit sind, ihm öffentlich zu unterstützen,
die äh es wird ich lese immer wieder auf Twitter oder so, dass jetzt äh muss Merkel dem Snowden Asyl geben. Also.
Ja? Also wir haben wir haben NATO, wir haben diese ganzen Bündnisse, wir haben die also Deutschland wird schön, schön.
Selbst wenn sie wollten, was sie bestimmt nicht wollen, würden sie nicht auch nur den Hauch einer Chance haben, ihnen irgendwas zu gewähren. Außer einen Satz Handschellen.
Die werden ganz schön die Füße stillhalten und er kann naturgemäß das liegt in der Sache, jetzt nur noch zu Ländern, die
entweder mit den USA ohnehin offen verfeindet sind oder keine Aktien mit den USA haben, ja? Ähm okay, aber also das.
Da gibt's ja gar nicht so viele. Ich meine auch Russland hat Aktien mit den USA, so ist es jetzt nicht, ja.
Ja, kommen wir mal, kommen wir mal zu Russland. Also,
Du sagst, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, ob überhaupt bestätigt ist, dass er dass ihn irgendjemand schon in Moskau gesehen hat, äh einer, der behauptet, dass er sich dort aufhält, ist auf jeden Fall äh Wladimir Putin,
Ähm und jetzt ist also in Moskau in Moskau saßen ja da gab's ja dann schöne Bilder von äh äh kam also über Twitter. Da ist dann so eine so eine Meute von Fotografen, saßen da so am Ausgang, ne, wurde wo der kam natürlich nicht raus.
Natürlich oder höchstwahrscheinlich nicht in Russland bleiben möchte, ja? Der wollte halt äh Transit machen und in eine nächste Maschine, vermutlich eben nach Venezuela oder Kuba,
Ähm gleichzeitig, während er also sich dort in diesem Transitbereich aufhielt und die Gerüchtelage war, okay, der nächste Flug nach äh äh auf den amerikanischen Kontinent geht ähm,
geht am Montag oder was, ja? Muss jetzt vierundzwanzig Stunden da im im Transit hängen. Äh währenddessen gab dann der ähm,
der äh der,
equadurianische Außenminister bekannt, dass jetzt hier ein Asylantrag vorlege von einem gewissen Edver Jazz Snowden.
Wisst ihr jetzt nicht genau, welcher Edward Jason? Es war ja nicht so ganz klar, ne? Ja.
So, aber ähm und was was noch äh was wir vergessen hatten zu erwähnen ist, dass diese gesamte äh,
Diese gesamte hol nimm doch Asyl in Ecuador an. Ich habe damit gute Erfahrungen,
die kam ja von Julio, ne? Also Julio hat ja schon bereits
öffentlich gesagt, wir empfehlen AdWords Snowden äh irgendwie nach äh in Ecuador Asyl zu beantragen. Wir haben da gute Erfahrungen mit gemacht. Schreibt schrieb er da so aus seiner Botschaft in New York,
bei Harrits. Und ähm,
berichtete ja dann auch, das fand ich ja sowieso also diese Wiki Leaks Rolle, da bin ich mal also das weiß ich eh nicht. Wiki League schrieb ja dann,
Zu seiner Reise, zu zu Snowdens Ausreise aus den USA, gab es dann Impress Statement von Wiki Leaks, dass er sich,
sich in der Begleitung von Human Rights Experts aus der,
Dynastie äh befindet und äh Wiki Leaks sich jetzt um den kümmert. Ähm ich weiß nicht ganz genau, also ich rieche da
Das riecht alles so ein bisschen nach
dass der Assance ein bisschen sauer ist, dass es ausgerechnet wieder beim gelandet ist und nicht bei ihm, ne? Also das wollen wir ja auch mal wohl bemerkt sagen, so der der Snowden hat sich an den
Green World gewendet und nicht an an den äh Assanches, ne? Also wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall versucht.
Der wollte ja auch, dass es veröffentlicht wird.
Gut, aber da, also lassen wir, lassen wir das.
Na ja, aber ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Problem, was viele äh hatten und wahrscheinlich auch immer noch haben, mit Wikidicks das ja, wie Kriegs in dem Sinne zäh war, nach eigenen strategischen Maßgaben, äh Dinge eben veröffentlicht hat oder nicht veröffentlicht hat.
Stimmt und er will das natürlich eher so, also orchestriert das ja jetzt vernünftig mit.
Das war ja auch zum Beispiel ein Grund, warum er äh nicht zur New York Times gegangen ist, was er auch durchaus erwogen hat,
dass er da eine Erfahrung gesammelt hätte, ähm dass da eine Geschichte ein Jahr gelegen hätte wegen,
Keine Ahnung, irgendeine Art von Bedenkenträgertum.
Ah okay, das war mir gar nicht so.
Dann hat er sie und dann hat er sich halt letztlich also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob der Guardian für ihn in gewisser Hinsicht schon immer der heißeste Kandidat war, aber das das war zumindest nicht komplett ausgeschlossen, dass nicht auch,
Die New York Times hätte der Medienpartner sein können, ist ja auf jeden Fall auch ein Medienschwergewicht, ja? Und ähm der Guardian hat ja einige Popularität mittlerweile auch im amerikanischen Raum,
und hat dann damit äh den Zuschlag erhalten.
Okay.
Das leuchtet ein. Auf jeden Fall wir waren an dem Punkt, er sitzt also jetzt mit mit in der Begleitung von WikiLeaks Experten äh in Moskau und am Montag flieg.
Angeblich und und vor allem hat ja Julio dann auch noch bekannt gegeben, er sei ja jetzt in Sicherheit.
Ja das, also die, es ist.
War auch noch eine ganz merkwürdige Meldung.
Es gibt immer noch es gibt ja immer noch so die Theorie, dass er in Wirklichkeit schon irgendwo ganz woanders ist, könnte halt sein, ja.
Wer weiß, vielleicht haben sie eine spektakuläre Flucht gemacht. Dann verstehe ich aber nicht, warum.
Putin das sagt, dass er da ist.
Warum Putin das sagt? Putin war ja dann ganz besonders geil, also äh es begab sich dann am Montag, war dann auf jeder äh Tageszeitung irgendwie oder am Dienstag war es dann in der Tageszeitung dieser leere Flugzeug äh Sitz auf dem in dem Flugzeug nach Kuba, in dem
alle oder nach Venezuela, wo auch immer das,
weil wir dachten, da sitzt der äh äh Eduardo jetzt drin. Und ähm dann äh saß er aber nicht, ja, gab's halt einen leeren Platz.
Und Eduardo.
So und und Putin, Putin setzte sich ja dann hin,
Stellte sich vor die Presse und sagte so ungefähr, ja, also da ist dieser ähm da ist dieser Edward Snowden, der äh ist da jetzt bei uns im Transitbereich.
Erst hieß es ja nur, er sei nicht in Russland eingereist.
Ja klar, ist er ja auch nicht. Also um das.
Sogar noch eine erste für sich abgeschlossene Information, so hatte ich das wahrgenommen. Dass zunächst einmal behauptet wurde, er sei ja nicht in Russland eingereist, sodass man auch noch den Schluss daraus hätte ziehen können, er sei halt auch überhaupt nicht dahin geflogen.
Ja, nee, der also kann man den Schluss kann man ziehen, aber den ziehen natürlich solche,
Also den, den verstehen die USA schon, was im Transitbereich ist, ne, also muss man was ist überhaupt ein Transitbereich? Ich komme äh zum großen Flughafen und steige dort oben, also ich fliege zum Beispiel von äh von Berlin nach äh Johannesburg, ja und steige um in Istanbul,
Flug gibt von Istanbul nach Johannesburg und ein Flug von von Berlin nach nach Istanbul und äh.
Genau und da muss man halt nicht die Einreiseformalien durchlaufen.
Genau. Dann geht man man kommt aus seinem Flugzeug raus, dann gibt's da noch äh und dann dann gibt's.
Es sei denn, man ist im Transitbereich in den USA, da sieht's schon ein bisschen anders.
Ja gut, da da sieht's anders aus und in Israel wahrscheinlich auch nochmal. Aber äh so ein normaler Transitbereich jetzt in in so einem Flughafen,
du raus, dein Gepäck ist unter Umständen schon direkt bis zur Destination durchgecheckt und dann gehst du halt da
Du läufst du quasi von deinem Ankunftsgeld zu deinem nächsten und zwischendurch gibt's so eine grobe Passkontrolle. Du reißt aber nicht in das Land ein. Das heißt, du hast nicht du bist offiziell nicht in diesem Land.
Sondern du bist.
Im Transitbereich.
Im Transitbereich äh offenen Gewässern. Das hat äh hat verschiedene Gründe, warum die das so machen. Ähm unter anderem glaube ich auch, damit,
Damit halt nicht jeder, der aus dem Flugzeug steigt, wirklich auch schon in deinem Land ist,
Ja, dass du halt wirklich da auch noch mal eine Grenze hast, sonst müsstest du die Grenze quasi in das andere Land legen. Also da ins Abflug geht. Also irgendwo muss eine Passkontrolle stattfinden und die findet halt,
nachher statt. So und damit du diesen Transit erleichtert hast
damit halt nicht jemand jeder erst einmal in die Türkei einreisen muss und dann da wieder ausreisen muss und dann wieder nach nach Afrika fliegt, gibt's halt einen Transitbereich im Flughafen und da hat offiziell erstmal keiner äh eine großartige Hoheit drüber. Da bist du auch nicht mehr in
diesem Land. Wer das äh wer in Tegel am Flughafen ankommt, läuft durch diesen Finger, holt sein Gepäck und dann steht da, sie kommen jetzt in die Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
Und genau in diesem Bereich äh rennt jetzt unser Eduardo Rum an, so will es die Legende und ähm,
hat keinen, hat keinen gültigen Pass, mit dem er nach Russland einreisen könnte, weil den haben die USA ja ungültig gemacht. Und so stellt sich dann der äh Putin hin und sagt, ja, also da ist dieser Mann,
Uns ist nicht bekannt, dass der irgendeine Straftat begangen hätte. Wir haben nichts gegen den. Ein freier Mann, bei uns im Transit. Ähm wir,
Der kann natürlich auch nicht bei uns einreisen, der hat ja gar keinen gültigen Pass, den können wir ja nicht reinlassen.
Den können wir ja nicht.
Und ähm wir,
hoffen natürlich, dass dass sie uns die USA das uns jetzt nicht übel nehmen, aber wir können ja jetzt nicht in den Transitbereich, da haben wir gar keine Hoheit drüber und ähm,
so je schneller der sich ähm entscheidet, wohin er weiterfliegen möchte, äh desto besser für für ihn und uns. Tut mir leid.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass,
Ich will nicht wissen, wie der, also der hat dabei auch keine Biene verzogen. Der hat ja, der ist ja, äh Putin ist ja Ex-KGB. Du siehst das auch, der hat so immer diesen diese absolute ähm
ausdruckslose Miene, ne, diese Augen, die immer leer sind, so, unter Folter, der der verrät nicht
Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der, als er dann da steif äh von seiner, von seinem kleinen Podest runtergegangen nach hinten ist, dass der sich da auch erstmal irgendwie äh sehr, sehr Schrott gelacht hat. So, also weil die Nummer, die war schon eisern. Das kann man sich auch angucken, dieses Statement wird dann so sehr bedauernd so, ja, also,
und ohne ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, sagt, ich hoffe, dass aber so so funktioniert halt Diplomatie, ne? Mhm.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, Reporter, also ich habe keinen Bericht gesehen, wo jemand jemand aus diesem Flugzeug, mit dem es mit dem angeblich geflogen sei, interviewt hätte, der meinte, er hätte ihn gesehen. Viel mehr,
so das ist das, was ich wahrgenommen habe. Ich habe da nun auch nicht den mega Überblick, aber es schien so, als ob sich niemand,
konkret zu diesem Foto, was so bekannt war, äußern konnte und sagen konnte, den habe ich hier sitzen gesehen,
andererseits. Warum sollte Putin behaupten, er sei da wenn er da nicht ist.
Also das wäre schon echt eisern. Also wenn der,
alles außen vor, aber wenn der Putin sich vor die versammelte Presse stellt und dann noch dem Snowden quasi Fluchthilfe leistet, indem er eine Falschinformation darüber abgibt, wo der Mensch sich befindet,
Das glaube ich, da das wäre zu hart.
Also da das wäre einfach diplomatisch unter diplomatischen Gesichtspunkten. Zu übel. Ich würde schon vermuten, dass er zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch tatsächlich dort im Transitbereich war.
Gut, das heißt, wir können auch davon ausgehen, dass er da vielleicht noch ist.
Genau, das ist der interessante,
es kann sehr gut sein, dass der Putin das genau in dem Moment gesagt hat, als der Snoden in irgendein Flugzeug gestiegen ist und irgendwo abzuhauen. Das wäre natürlich sehr schön, weil man dann weiß, dass dann alle erstmal äh einen Tag lang sich darüber äh unterhalten, dass er jetzt da in diesem Transit ist und währenddessen fliegt er schön gemütlich woanders hin, ja. Also
Man weiß es nicht. Also es sieht.
Die Journalisten sind da ja da auch kräftig durch diesen Transitbereich gelatscht, haben sich natürlich alle möglichen Tickets gekauft, um da irgendwie äh sich umzuschauen, aber es ist natürlich, wie nicht anders zu erwarten war von ihm. Ist nicht so, dass er jetzt irgendwo in der Ecke mit dem Schlafsack,
auf sein, seit drei Tagen ausgefallenen Anschlussflug nach äh Kuba wartet, so.
In dem Transitbereich gibt's ja dann durchaus auch noch so, weiß nicht. Da gibt's ja äh.
Räume für Spezialbehandlungen.
Räume, da wird ja schon dann irgendwo.
Ganz sicher, dass sie da im Bereich Spezialbehandlungen da in Russland auch sehr wie soll ich sagen, ausgefeilte Methoden.
Äh also was jetzt so an diese, also diese, diese Fluchtgeschichte, die ja jetzt schon so irgendwie so wo ist etwa? Snowden, ja, die letzten Tage, die Medien äh äh,
beschäftigt hat, also spannende, witzige Geschichte, ne? Man hofft natürlich irgendwie, dass dieser Mann jetzt irgendwie so, man weiß nicht, wo geht er hin, ne? Es gibt ähm
eine schöne Karte bei äh Wikipedia. Das äh kann man sich auch klein ausdrucken, wenn das Portemonnaie legen. Ähm die Liste der Länder, die Auslieferungsabkommen mit den USA haben.
Schöne Landkarte, da sind dann so blaue und so weiter Punkte. Ich habe den äh Link noch nicht in den. Ich suche die nochmal kurz raus.
In der englischen Wikipedia nehme ich an.
Natürlich, dass wir das dann für Deutsche wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht relevant. Äh.
Oder sowas.
Ja und da gibt's ein schönes Countrys, Lightblue, in, so, das ne, da kann man also sehen.
Sehr hübsch. Ne, da kann man also sehen. Das ist zum Beispiel komplett äh Südamerika, einschließlich Equador.
So, jetzt muss ich aber gucken, welche.
Oder? Habe ich jetzt die Farbe falsch dekodiert?
Ja, ich versuche grade hier die Legende ist irgendwie nicht auf dem großen, wo ist es denn? Ja, haben sie.
Aber.
Aber Norbert.
Also in der Regel, wir erinnern uns, das war ja auch schon die Frage bei, bei Schweden, dass diese Expedition
sich darauf beziehen, dass die Straftat auch in dem Lande wiederum eine wäre oder sonstige Sachen. Also und wenn Equador sagt, Asyl, dann ist das ja sowieso nochmal eine andere äh.
Ja ja klar, dem können sie sich natürlich entziehen.
Aber es gibt hier eine schöne, also für die für die Hosentasche, für die Westentasche, wenn man mal auf der Flucht ist, äh kann man diese kleine Karte sich so, ne, die kann man schön so in.
Ja, ist sehr interessant, sehr interessant, ja. Hm.
Also genau, während dieser während diese diese schöne lustige Geschichte da irgendwie läuft, die wahrscheinlich für den Snowden gar nicht so lustig ist, ja, der äh für den geht's da ja dann doch um ein Leben in unter widrigen Bedingungen oder äh,
Leben in lebenslanger Haft. Ähm währenddessen gibt dann der Green World bekannt, dass ähm.
Noch mehr Informationen gesteckt bekommen hat.
Und dass der Snowden vor allem auch so einen hat, ja, also dass er
auch irgendwie eine Datei an Personen geschickt hat und die Schlüssel an andere und sollte er verschwinden oder ihm etwas äh passieren, dass er dass dann diese Sachen halt alle äh rausfallen, also diesen gleichen Nord hatte sicher
Studienaustausch auch schon vor ein paar Jahren einfallen lassen. Ist ja auch ein interessanter.
Todmann-Taste.
Genau, ist ein interessanter Witz. Es ist ein interessantes Ding. Man weiß halt nicht, vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur ein ein großzügiges Backup von äh Defradom. Aber äh.
Ja, er meinte ja auch so, er hätte ja in seiner Position eigentlich so Zugriff auf so ziemlich alles gehabt, einschließlich a la NSA Agenten, Personen, Mitarbeiter, trallala, so und das ist natürlich auch etwas, also ich,
kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass das was ist, aber ich glaube, dass es auf jeden Fall äh von den USA erwogen werden muss, dass,
Ja, solche Informationen hat und gegebenenfalls eben auch auf diese Art und Weise äh auszuspielen bereit ist. Und da stehen die, da stehen die gar nicht drauf.
Ich will, ich will das auch ganz ehrlich aus, also vielleicht nachher nochmal so aus der aus der Ratio eines Staates einfach mal betrachten, warum die da jetzt alle so agieren. Mehr braucht man sich ähm,
Also ich für mich persönlich ist da weder etwas äh Überraschendes dran, noch etwas besonders M
wie die USA, zumindest jetzt auf den Snowden reagieren.
Also du musst so reagieren, anstatt der ist gar keine andere Wahl. Du kannst ja nicht irgendwie Whistle Blower aus deinem Geheimdienst irgendwie
nach China abhauen lassen, ne? Aber das ist genau der Punkt, das ist genau das Problem. Snowden stellt sich jetzt hin und erzählt in einem, in einem Presseinterview,
dass er das alles vorbereitet hätte und sagt, er.
Was alles vorbereitet.
Ja, dass er, dass er im Prinzip dieser gesamten äh dieser Blackwater House Coopers oder wie die heißen. Price, nee, wie heißen die Nummer, die? Ich ich mische hier die Namen äh äh Hamilton,
Ich komme da irgendwie, warte.
Also diese Firma auf jeden Fall, bei der er zuletzt gearbeitet hat, die im Auftrag von NSA gewirkt hat, dass er bewusst die Position dort gesucht hat. Ja. Um an diese Informationen auch heranzukommen. Also diesen diesen Zugangslevel zu erhalten.
Ähm da das ähm Hamilton.
Ja.
Hieß die Firma. Und ich habe sie verwechselt mit Price Water House. Price Waterhouse Cooper und das ist natürlich.
Wahrscheinlich auch gleichzeitig noch mit Black water, um's irgendwie. Das ist aber.
Oder Preis, das ist aber was anderes.
Genau wie Blackwater. Das ist ein wir haben auch alle irgendwie Dreck am Stecken, aber ja.
Wirtschaftsprüfer, Pricewater aus Coopers. Ja, also das äh ja, ein freundlicher Versprecher. Auch in der letzten Sendung gab es wieder mehrere. Ich wir wurden darauf hingewiesen, ähm also,
Hamilton. Äh Pibapo, also äh Hamilton, ja? Bei denen äh hat er nur drei Monate gearbeitet und hat dann gesagt, dass er mit dem einzigen Ziel, der äh Informationsextraktion überhaupt diesen Job angenommen hat,
Ähm,
Das ist natürlich einerseits jetzt aus aus meiner Perspektive eine sehr äh ein sehr heldenhaftes Opfer, was dieser äh Mensch dann da gebracht hat, ja, dass er quasi gesagt hat, ich gehe da irgendwie rein und äh opfere mein,
Im Prinzip opferst du deinen deinen kompletten Lebensinhalt dieser Aufgabe, weil du wirst dein Leben nicht mehr normal in Frieden führen können nach so einer Nummer. Ähm,
Andererseits,
macht er sich damit natürlich ein bisschen angreifbar und nimmt so diese schöne Geschichte, die ich eigentlich lieber von ihm gehört hätte, äh zunichte, dass er nämlich sagt, ich bin als absoluter Patriot.
Rein und dann habe ich gesehen, wie sie alle Scheiße gebaut haben und bin irgendwie zu Überzeugung gekommen, so geht's nicht.
Genau, das ist natürlich eine Geschichte, die ihr schöner gerade den den äh Amerikanern erzählen kann.
Na, okay, das ist eine Frage der Darstellung. Der war's ja zweistufig am Anfang war's ja wohl genauso.
Na ja, also er behauptet jetzt, dass er äh oder so habe ich den Teil jetzt verstanden, dass er eben diese diesen Job nur deshalb angenommen hätte. Wie dem auch sei, im Detail fragt er ja keiner mehr nach
ähm wenn er das einmal so sagt, dann äh die Schlagzeile ist da, ne? Und äh jetzt wird er natürlich auch äh dafür,
gegrillt, ja? Also es gab ja sogar in Deutschland dann die Berichte, die sagen, ähm dieser Mann ist äh,
kein, sondern Verräter und äh in den USA kannst du dir ungefähr vorstellen, was da jetzt,
Über ihn geschrieben wird. Also PR mäßig äh ist er gerade, sitzt er in der Tinte. Ähm,
Dazu eben zu sagen, so, er kann nur in Länder gehen, die bereit sind, äh den USA mal irgendwie einen kleinen Stinke oder einen kleinen oder einen großen Stinkefinger zu zeigen. Das heißt, er kann nicht irgendwie in
in äh in irgendwelche EU-Länder oder sowas, das kann er vollständig vergessen. Ähm,
und zweitens äh ist es auch.
Irgendwie verständlich, dass diese dass diese Länder, die den USA ein Stinkefinger zeigen wollen, ihn jetzt auch nicht unbedingt aus äh Mitgefühl aufnehmen, ne. Also ich meine, Russland
steht der NSA sicherlich in nichts nach. Und genauso tut es Deutschland nicht, wir hatten das letzte Woche ja schon behandelt,
dass das Deutschland gleichzeitig die die Geheimdienstetats jetzt irgendwie erhöhen will, genauso wie jedes andere Land der Welt zu England kommen wir gleich. Ja, das heißt, die tun sich da alle nichts. Also auf dem internationalen Parkett,
ist das jetzt einfach nur 'ne ist das jetzt 'ne Strategie Sache? Jedes einzelne Land was da irgendwo mitmacht hat genauso seine Geheimdienste
achtet genauso nicht die die die Kommunikationsprivilegien seiner Bürger und insbesondere nicht der seiner Nichtbürger, ja? Es sind ja immer Auslandsgeheimnisse
und unter dem ähm,
auf die unter dieser Perspektive ist da geht's da auch nicht um irgendeinen Whistleblower, ja? Also da ist jedem einzelnen Land bekannt, dass dass das bei ihnen auch ein Verräter wäre.
Und da gibt's ja auch diese schöne äh immer wieder äh so, wo das mal umgeschrieben wird. Jetzt nenn den Eduards äh Edward Snowden einfach mal, gib dem Chinesischen Namen,
überleg jetzt mal ob irgendwas an der Geschichte anders wäre, wenn das im Geiste durchspielst, wenn das jetzt ein Chinese wäre,
der über die äh Filter oder äh Überwachungsmethoden Chinas berichtet und dann in die USA fliegt,
Da würden die USA doch auch sagen, ja freier Mann, also wie sehen wir jetzt hier nix böses dran so, ne? Also kann sich gerne bei uns ein Haus kaufen, so wir haben günstige Kredite, so also weißt du, den.
Ja.
Ähm das heißt auf dem auf dem internationalen Parkett spielt diese moralische,
Der moralische Aspekt dieser ganzen Überwachungs scheiße da gar keine Rolle. Und ich glaube, dass inzwischen sogar ähm,
Also ich bin eigentlich mit dem Verlauf sehr unglücklich, ja? Alle alle Welt kümmert sich darum, wo AdWords no ist, ja, ist eine wichtige Sache. Hätten wir uns mal bei Bradley Menning früher drum kümmern können so, ne, dann äh sparen wir uns auch unsere äh unsere Märtyrer. Aber ähm,
Letztendlich die Enthüllung selber, ja, die die plätschern da so vor sich hin, ne. Ähm,
Also der der politische, der politische Aspekt, da kommen wir ja gleich nochmal zu dieser Enthüllung, der äh ist dann da schon irgendwie dann enttäuschend.
Wer interessant ist ja überhaupt, dass er gleich von Anfang an äh diese ganze Enthüllung mit seinem Namen verbunden hat und aus seinem Gesicht.
Also er hätte ja nun auch genauso vergleicht, der hat zwar die Informationen geliefert, aber halt nur aus eigener Dummheit letztlich seine Identität äh offenbart und hätte diese Dummheit nicht an den Tag gelegt, wäre vielleicht auch immer noch,
ein freier Mensch. Hunos, ja vielleicht auch nicht, keine Ahnung, aber Tatsache ist, er hat sich da im Wesentlichen selber ans Messer geliefert,
Durch diese Unachtsamkeit im Chat. Und bei Snowden war's halt ganz anders. Erst gleich von vorne rein, ich meine, er hätte ja im Prinzip auch versuchen können, eine Strategie zu wählen, wie diese Information äh zum Guardian kommen, ohne,
Automatisch mit seiner Person zu verknüpfen.
Ja, ich glaube, also ich würde, ich hätte es an seiner Stelle wahrscheinlich nicht anders gemacht,
Und zwar aus dem einfachen Grunde heraus, dass das dann deine einzige Lebensversicherung ist, das möglichst viele Menschen wissen, wer du bist, wo du dich aufhältst und dass du lebst.
Das kann schon sein. Das ist trotzdem bemerkenswert so und mal was Neues.
Aber ich meine, der Typ hat halt die Überwachungsinfrastruktur gesehen, der wird sich auch überlegt haben, welche Chance er hat, da sein Leben unentdeckt zu.
Ja genau, das äh,
Das finde ich auch ganz interessant und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es ihm ja auch gelungen.
Bis dahin so, ne? Und jetzt müssen wir schauen, ob ob Moskau eine Sackgasse äh ist für ihn. Ich meine, was kann ein Moskau jetzt schon gut machen, einreisen lassen, ihm Asyl gewähren?
Nee, das wird kein, also die äh die diplomatischen Spannungen werden da zu groß. Ich glaube nicht, dass.
Können ja gegen andere Spione tauschen, solche Vorschläge gab's natürlich auch schon von den äh etwas polternden, darin äh Abgeordneten der Duma, hier diese, wie heißt dieser, dieser Vollidiot äh im rechten Lager,
gerade den Namen nicht zusammen, aber die haben doch da so diverse Überalkoholisierte äh äh,
Menschen, die irgendwie nicht klar denken können und die sind natürlich schon auf die wildesten Ideen gekommen, ihn gleich als Pfand zu verwenden und einzutauschen, gegen irgendwie ihre äh Verbrecher, die sozusagen in den USA einsitzen.
Was äh.
Waffenhändler wollten sie irgendwie wieder zurückhaben und so.
Was Equador angeht, wurde dann jetzt von Seiten der USA freundlich darauf hingewiesen, dass es ja ähm Handelsvereinbarungen gäbe zwischen,
Equador und den USA,
Und ähm dass es sich dabei ja nicht um Selbstverständlichkeiten, sondern um Privilegien handelt,
Und ähm dass die ja auch nächstes Jahr wieder in neu verhandelt werden, ja?
Und da müsste man sich natürlich jetzt keine ähm.
Schöne haben wir da. Wäre doch schade, wenn dir was passieren würde,
Ja. Ne, sicherlich ist der, ähm er ist noch gleich hier, der gerade die,
Ja, genau. Na ja, also ich meine, ist sicherlich nicht abgeneigt, da seine Rolle nochmal zu nutzen,
Andererseits dürfte er innenpolitisch auch eine ganze Menge äh Druck aus anderen Richtungen bekommen und diese beliebige äh alles gegen die USA ist cool. Nummer lässt sich natürlich auch nicht beliebig,
durchziehen, weil so oder so
egal wie viel sie da intern anderer Formen ähm vorangebracht haben, sich komplett mit den USA zu verscherzen, macht jetzt auch keinen Spaß. Auf der anderen Seite äh ist es auch, glaube ich, für die USA jetzt nicht beliebig,
so, dass sie jetzt sagen können, so, ah, hier, ein, ein souveräner Staat macht etwas, was uns nicht passt. Jetzt lassen wir hier die äh Millionen leiden
nicht unbedingt der Iran, ja? Ich meine, Equador will jetzt nicht irgendwie Atomraketen äh bauen und äh äh nach Norden fliegen lassen, sondern es geht da nur,
Um einen Menschen.
Die USA halten seit seit Jahrzehnten Handelsembargo gegen Kuba aufrecht. Kriegen dafür jedes Jahr in der UN gesagt, dass das absolut daneben ist, von allen Ländern der Erde außer Israel,
wird gibt's jedes Jahr in der UN entschieden irgendwie 'ne Rüge an die USA.
Ja gut, aber das hat eine ganz andere Geschichte und äh so ein Land, wo sie auch mal so explizit alle rausgetrieben wurden, die Amerikaner und enteignet wurden und so weiter und das ist vor allem jetzt noch so
schmerzt die, glaube ich, vor allem deshalb, weil sie es irgendwie in fünfzig Jahren nicht geschafft haben, direkt vor ihrer eigenen Haustür irgendwas mal in die andere Richtung zu bewegen
Da ist Äquador ein anderer Fall. Na klar,
wissen wir alle, dass die USA eine Menge Macht haben und Möglichkeiten haben und ich will das auch gar nicht ausschließen, dass dieser Druck schon ausreicht, um ein Asyl in Equador zu verhindern,
nur auch die USA haben hier was zu verlieren. Ja, also äh.
Ja ja, die können auch nicht ohne Ende da rumfeuern. Die müssen auch aufpassen, aber äh unterschätze nicht irgendwie eine auf.
Unterschätze.
Macht.
Ich unterstütze hier auch auch keinen, aber ich meine, genauso kann man auch dann das das Ego von dem Korea nicht äh unterschätzen und äh auch die Interessen anderer und am Ende kann auch immer noch Kuba sagen. Komm doch zu uns. Uns kann eh nichts mehr passieren.
Schlimmer kann's nicht werden.
Venezuela hat übrigens auch noch gesagt, äh dass er ähm.
Mindestens durchfliegen darf, ja.
Nee, die haben sogar gesagt, also sie könnten sich könnten sich kaum vorstellen, dass ein Asylantrag von ihm abgelehnt würde, ja. Äh.
Abgelehnt werden würde. Ja, das na ja, also gibt durchaus Möglichkeiten.
Ja? Aber ne, also klar
Es ist einfach, man muss einfach sagen, so Deutschland würde sich kaum anders ähm
Kein anderer Staat der Welt würde sich großartig anders verhalten als die USA jetzt. Es ist ein Staat und sie haben einen Geheimdienst und da ist ihnen gerade einer äh abtrünnig geworden und das ist eine ähm,
Das ist das steht halt nochmal auf einem anderen Blatt als das äh als die tatsächlichen Enthüllung. Und deswegen,
Glaube ich, ist jetzt schwierig für den Snowden gerade. Okay.
Boulevardteil.
Kommen wir, kommen wir zu den Enthüllungen, denn es gab ja auch noch äh den den Punkt, dass der Snowden sich bei,
unbeliebt gemacht hat, denn er hat das Government Communication Headquarters Programm temporär äh,
enthüllt und hat gesagt, ja, seit anderthalb Jahren ungefähr, haben die Briten so ein ähnliches Programm wie die NSA und die höheren haben ihre Schnorchel an insgesamt zweihundert Glasfaserverbindungen,
Die jeweils so zehn Gigabit umfassen und können davon sechsundvierzig Stück Simultan abschnorcheln,
dass es ihre äh momentane Kapazität in der äh in der Überwachung von,
Transkontinentalverbindung, denn wir wissen ja, oder vielleicht wissen wir es auch nicht, wie kommt das Internet von Europa in die USA, dann liegt ein langer, langer, langer, dicker dicker, dicker Lichtleiter im Meer. Und nicht nur einer, sondern sehr viele, gibt's eine schöne Karte für drüber,
und ähm an diesem, diese Glasfaserverbindungen äh,
haben dann offensichtlich die Briten ihre äh Schnorchel dranhängen, insbesondere an dem Kabel an der an der Glasfaserleitung TAT vierzehn,
wo so der Großteil der Kommunikation äh Deutschlands mit den USA durchfließt. Ähm,
Dann gab's ein.
Nochmal das Kabel.
TAT vier Zentrums Atlantic so und so,
Ja, guck mal. Müsste dann halt von Großbritannien irgendwo oh die haben eine ganze Menge Kabel.
Ja, es ist überhaupt interessant, also was was das so besonders macht, ist, dass die wesentlichen Verbindungen zwischen den USA und Europa laufen über äh Großbritannien, also ich schaue hier gerade mal,
sieht so aus, als ob's hier.
Ich glaub das einzige was hier nicht direkt auf dem Festland landet das landet dann in Gibraltar oder so also da ist auf jeden Fall.
Ist auch unglaublich, wie viel wie viel Glas die da schon in den Teich gelegt haben.
Ne, es gibt es gibt ein paar auch von von Frankreich, aber das ist sozusagen sehr wenig und äh so auf den ersten Eindruck würde ich sagen, ein Großteil so gefühlt achtzig, neunzig äh Prozent aller Kabelverbindungen,
direkt in die USA laufen über Britannien und von daher ist das einmal auch der optimale Punkt.
Und schau dir, schau dir mal das THT vierzehn an, das geht nämlich nicht nur von USA nach Großbritannien, sondern äh.
Äh T A T vierzehn.
So. Und das geht nämlich sogar das geht. Großbritannien, Frankreich das ist ein Ring.
Ist ein Ring, also USA, Großbritannien, dann Frankreich schauen wir mal kurz.
Ist er nach Holland oder so? Ja, Niederlande?
Das war jetzt gerade hier. Wir versuchen hier grade interaktive.
Wir sind halt unglaublich viele.
Was ein bisschen.
Also Niederlande, also Amsterdam vermutlich und dann aber auch nochmal in Deutschland das Kabel und in Dänemark.
In Dänemark. Und dann geht's von Dänemark irgendwie zurück, weiß der Geier, wieso sie das da nochmal gelegt haben. Ja, werden sich, wenn sich wat bei gedacht haben.
Ja, wo ist denn das in Deutschland? Im Norden.
Norden,
So diese Kabel und jetzt sagen die äh jetzt sagen die äh Briten also an zweihundert von denen haben wir ein Schnorchel. Und dann kam natürlich die äh die Debatte auf, ja wie hören die denn die Glasfaserkabel ab und dann gab's irgendwie Berichte über U-Boote, die zu dem Kabel hinfahren
Ähm und ja ja und das Biegen, dann hast du so einen minimalen optischen Austritt. Unterm Wasser ist das aber sehr dunkel. Das heißt, du kannst da die,
Die Futuren detektieren und dann auf der Festplatte in deinem U-Boot speichern oder so, also relativ.
Das halte ich auch jetzt mal für ein Gerücht.
Haltet auch mal für ein Gerücht.
Die Glasfaser ist in einem Mantel, der in einem Mantel ist, der in einem Mantel ist, der in einem Mantel ist und die beiden äußersten Mantel sind definitiv da aus Stahl. Also da kriegst du nichts gebogen.
Du könntest natürlich auch mit deinem U-Wood das die Glasfaser schneiden und irgendwie so eine so eine Art Spiegeldetect alles totaler.
Könnte sein, dass sie es auspendeln.
Es könnte einfach sein, dass dir diese Station da hinstellen und ihre, ihre Monitoring-Equipment da reinschrauben. Irgendwo kommt das,
Kabel an und also niemand wird, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass niemand mit dem U-Boot irgendwo hinfährt, diese Glasfaserkabel anschneidet.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass es Forschungen in dem Bereich gibt, ganz klar dann im im militärischen Bereich, ganz klar, ich meine, die müssen,
im im Kriegsfall, aber dann auch dann schneiden sie sich das Kabel an, sondern irgendwie eine der Stationen des Kabels, die unterwegs liegt, weil der Laser, der in das Kabel reinleuchtet, der reicht ja nicht einmal durchs gesamte Meer. Da werden also zwischendurch sind da nochmal Stationen dran oder so. Also
relativ sicher, dass diese äh Legenden äh dass das eher im Bereich der Legenden ist, dass diese,
aber ne, wie wir sehen, es gibt dann eben diese Station, wo diese Kabel ankommen und da haben wir halt relativ viele äh in United Kingdom,
wo dann eben wichtige Glasfaserkabel ankommen. Und äh an diesen,
letztendlich sind das ja auch nur Switches, ja und da äh scheint dann einfach irgendwo noch ein Reck neben zu stehen,
Ähm wo dann die Datenextraktion erfolgt. Ich hatte es ja schon mal hier auch angedeutet, das funktioniert in der Regel so ähm,
Das einfach mal alles, was da durchgeht, gespiegelt wird oft noch mal eine zweite Verbindung. Und diese,
Diese Verbindung ähm können dann die Geheimdienste nach ihren nach ihren Gutdünken äh analysieren.
Genau, also es sieht so aus, als ob äh,
zwei sich vielleicht ergänzender aber sowohl in äh Ausführung als auch Ausführen als auch äh,
Stoßrichtungen sich stark unterscheidende Überwachungsprojekte aufgedeckt wurden von Herrn äh Eduardo ähm,
Ich glaube, das muss man unterscheiden und das wird, glaube ich, äh derzeit nicht so richtig unterschieden. Prisum ist im Wesentlichen ein Programm, um Zugriff zu erhalten bei Firmen.
Oder habe ich das äh den Scorp da falsch äh eingeschätzt? Zumindestens das ein großer Teil davon und bei äh Timpora geht's halt vor allem wirklich um das aktive Abschnorchen in der Leitung on the go.
Ah ja, ja, ich, ja, das kann man so sagen. Also bei bei Prisum haben sie ihren ihren äh ihren
eigenes Gericht, was jeden Antrag äh äh jedem Antrag stattgibt, offene Datenextraktion,
Und bei äh bei Tempra haben sie äh,
unter Geheimhaltung liegende äh Kooperation mit den Betreibern dieser Kommunikationsinfrastruktur. Ja, also das äh,
in dem Tempo wird das genannt, sie haben die sie einerseits zur Kooperation zwingen,
gleichzeitig zur Verschwiegenheit zwingen und im Gegenzug ihren Namen nirgendwo erwähnen. Aber wenn da irgendwie dieses THT vierzehn, das kommt irgendwo an, da steht ein,
Da steht eine Anlage, wo dieses Kabel reinkommt. Von da aus wird's äh wird's dann weiterverteilt in die Internete der Welten oder des europäischen Kontinents. Und ähm
da wird das deren Equipment stehen, ja, also warum sollten die sich da irgendwie das komplizierter machen?
Vorhaltedauer ähm bei äh dreißig Tage, Telefonate, E-Mails et cetera, fünfhundert Mitarbeiter.
Ja und eben hängt an der Grenze zwischen oder hängt an der an dem Hauptkabel über das Kommunikation zwischen Nordamerika und Westeuropa geht.
Gesetzliche Grundlage in den, in, in UK dafür ist der Ulripa, der der Regulation of Investicutory Powers Act,
wo gesagt wird, dass der äh ich glaube, der Außenminister, statt einer Einzelanordnung, auch so ein Grundzertifikat für Kategorien von Material,
ausstellen kann.
Diese Art von Material dürft ihr abschnorcheln.
Genau,
Und auch da, wenn ein Ende der Kommunikation im Ausland liegt, dann natürlich bei so einem Glasfaserkabel geil, weil äh ein auf jeden Fall so eine Teilstrecke äh der Kommunikation liegt im Ausland, ne. Ähm,
haben dann wohl offen zugegeben, dass irgendwie Betrug Terrorismus und Schleuserei da durchaus schon mal Untersuchungskriterien waren,
Aber äh über die aktuelle Analysen, die sie auf dem Kabel fahren, machen sie natürlich keine,
Aussage. Das ist wieder das gleiche Programm, wie wir auch in äh in Deutschland dann haben, wo man sagt, okay, Kommunikation, solange Einkommunikationspartner im Ausland ist, äh können wir da dadran rumschnorcheln,
Und äh rundrum analysieren. Und mit fünfhundert Mann und und einer größeren Geldsumme an Hardware kannst du halt auch problemlos machen.
Ja, unsere deutsche Regierung war dann auf jeden Fall äh natürlich gleich,
wieder in der Situation sich irgendwie erklären zu müssen wegen dieser temporär Geschichte, so nach dem Motto, habt ihr denn überhaupt irgendwas gewusst? Und wenn ihr was gewusst habt, warum habt ihr nichts gesagt? Und wenn ihr irgendwie nichts gewusst habt, warum habt ihr das nicht gewusst? Also sie konnten auch irgendwie nicht das Richtige antworten an der Stelle
So oder so, haben dann irgendwie äh ganz empörungsmäßig dann erstmal Haarwärmen. Da müssen wir mal nachfragen und so und wir schicken da jetzt ein
also wir setzen sozusagen das das gesamte Gewicht der deutschen Diplomatie ein und schicken einen Fragebogen.
Da wackelt natürlich der Oberlisk äh in London, ne, da ist äh.
Und dann hat, was haben die Briten zurückgeschrieben? Die Regierung ihrer Majestät äußert sich grundsätzlich nicht zu den Tätigkeiten ihrer Geheimdienste. Ja, natürlich nicht. Ist ein Geheimdienst, Mann.
Das ist irgendwer so als als ob du einen Brief zu Apple schickst und fragst, wann irgendwie.
Das neue MacBook raus.
Ja, genau. Etwa dasselbe Level.
Also ja, also so,
der antwortet der Praktikant mit dem äh also das das seid ihr totaler Witz, ne?
Ja, da geht dann die Regierung wahrscheinlich dann in die Öffentlichkeit, hat gesagt, ja, wir haben natürlich mit Nachdruck äh ja, versucht, Informationen zu erhalten und haben auch welche bekommen, nämlich das uns nichts gesagt.
Toneinspieler wenige Tage, davon wenige Tage davor ähm ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schnell hinkriegen, aber was ich ja sehr schön.
An den richtigen Ort, in die Dropbox schmeißt zum Beispiel.
Es wäre sogar ein äh ach so, man braucht hier Flash oder sowas. Hast du hier Flash auf deiner? Hast du so Flash?
Du kannst es auch hier an die äh an die Airport, die Airport.
Ich habe kein Flash.
Was hast du denn da für einen Dateichen.
Video von Spiegel DE.
Schmeiß das mal in die Box.
Ist ein Flash Video von Spiegel DE.
Ich kann net, ich habe hier mein neuer Computer, ich habe einen neuen Computer übrigens, liebe Hörer, ich habe einen neuen Computer. So und da ist noch, den habe ich seit gestern und da ist kein.
Gib mir doch mal die URL.
Da wollte ich drauf hinaus. Wie ähm wie mache ich das denn jetzt mal in Mail.
Wohl nicht so kompliziert. Das wollen auch die Leute nicht hören. Solche organisatorischen Hintergrundtätigkeiten möchten einfach, dass es hier flutscht und dass man das Gefühl hat, man hat es mit Profis.
Also per E-Mail fliegt fliegt jetzt bei dir eine URL rein, die hätte es aber eigentlich auch da schon direkt klicken können. Ähm Innenminister Friedrich Kritik an NSA Überwachung ist.
Ja ist eine Misch.
Das das können wir uns dann live anhören, ja? In München. Da kannst du klicken. Ja und jetzt hören, sie hören.
Wo soll ich jetzt draufklicken? Ah, da soll ich klicken. Muss ich jetzt das Ganze mit der Werbung äh abspielen? Warte ich mal, ich habe erstmal Angst, dass hier Werbung kommt. Äh.
Erstmal ohne Ton kommen. Ah, das ist keine Werbung, das ist der Innenminister,
und das ist ein Reuters-Video und wir hören dann jetzt gleich mal, was das ist. Das war am siebzehnten Sechsten, also,
vor zehn Tagen. Da waren also war dieser ähm britische Kram noch nicht bekannt, aber äh es war gerade das große Geschrei über die
USA mit ihrem Prisum Programm.
Rainer, fahr ab.
Also der Sinnzusammenhang, ah, da ist die Werbung.
Ah ja.
Die äh der äh Sinnzusammenhang erschließt sich natürlich sofort,
Ja das ist, das sagt der, sagte der Innenminister am siebzehnten sechsten, inzwischen sitzt er dann da und.
Fand ich aber jetzt nicht so überraschend.
Natürlich? Ja, ich finde das.
Also was war da jetzt so zitierungswürdig?
Irgendwie Antiamerikanismus zu unterstellen. Also ich finde das schon, ich finde das schon äh finde das schon äh sehr.
Findest du sicherlich aber auch in dieser ganzen Debatte. Also da machen wir uns mal nichts vor, ja?
In der letzten in der letzten Folge schon mal kurz äh angemerkt. Also Fakt ist, man braucht sich da keine keine Illusion hinzugeben. Deutschland äh hat ähnliche Programme äh mit ähnlichen Ambitionen,
Ähm aber dann gab's ja noch diese schöne, also eine leere Debatte im Bundestag und es sind einfach alle,
ratlos, ja? Die Briten sagen, ja äh wir äußern uns grundsätzlich nicht zu den zu unseren geheimdienstlichen Tätigkeiten, seid ihr bescheuert, da diese Frage zu stellen. Es,
es wäre jetzt eigentlich mal angezeigt, ja, dass man, dass man im Rahmen dieser dieser ganzen Europa- und EU-Nummer da mal sich mal echt bei den Briten erkundigt, ob die irgendwie den den äh knallig gehört haben, dass sie diese Daten nicht mit den anderen Geheimdiensten teilen
ja? Also ich meine, das ist ja, dass er das Niveau auf den Regierungen dann da diskutieren,
Die Briten werden ja nicht damit aufhören. Das einzige, was jetzt irgendwie passieren wird, ist, dass die, dass der, dass der BND sagt, hör mal, Jungs, ihr könnt doch nicht da diese Daten sammeln ohne uns davon was abzugeben.
Das ist doch das einzige, was was jetzt ernsthaft da die äh auf Regierungsebene des äh das diplomatische Problem ist.
Um da mal äh ein bisschen Zynismus in die Debatte zu bringen. Entsprechend leer war dann auch die äh die Bundestagsdebatte zu diesem Thema,
und ähm im Unterausschuss neue Medien sagte ja selbst, dass äh,
dass äh der Vertreter vom äh Innenministerium ja also äh grundsätzlich, dass sie das Internet überwachen, davon waren wir nicht überrascht äh das kann ja niemand behaupten, äh der sich damit ein bisschen beschäftigt, ja, also,
Insofern, diese antiamerikanismus Sache sehe ich nur dann, wenn wenn Menschen jetzt ernsthaft meinen, dass nur die USA wären, die soweit machen.
Ja, na gut, wie auch immer. Also.
Aber ich habe auch keinen Bock, mich als Anti-Amerikaner äh brandmarken zu lassen, weil ich irgendwie ein Problem mit so einer Form von Überwachung habe.
Ja, also das ist auch nichts, sagen wir mal, glaube ich,
was jetzt irgendwie mit Anti oder Pro Amerika oder irgendein anderes Land zu tun hat, ja, man kann äh Amerika da äh äh lieben oder generell Scheiße finden oder auch Britannien oder meinetwegen auch Deutschland. Ähm,
Hier geht ja die die Debatte einfach grundsätzlich auf dem Verhältnis zwischen,
Entschuldigung. Ähm hier geht die Debatte grundsätzlich zu zwischen,
Volk und Staat und sein Verhältnis zueinander. Das, das ist einfach die Grundfrage, die jetzt hier wieder äh in den Raum gespielt wird, so und die aufgeklärte,
Ähm Privatsphäre und Überwachungssensitive Gemeinde, die es seit den achtziger Jahren gibt für die diese ganze Computerwelle steht, der CCC steht et cetera und was ja auch in Deutschland einfach über lange Zeit einen Zeitgeist,
und in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch ist, die sieht sich natürlich äh bestätigt in ihren schlimmsten Befürchtungen, beziehungsweise,
hat eigentlich auch nie einen Zweifel daran gehabt, dass es jetzt eben schon soweit ist. Jetzt kann man's bloß mal konkret benennen und es ist eben nicht nur so eine Behauptung, eine Vermutung, sondern es ist eben einfach konkret.
Jetzt stellt man aber auf der anderen Seite auch fest, dass es eben auch einen großen Teil in der Öffentlichkeit gibt, die einfach nur mit den Schultern zuckt und sagt, ja,
Und was war jetzt irgendwie die Nachricht eigentlich? Also es ist vielleicht auch so das, was für den Herrn Snowden noch mal das größte Problem sein könnte, ne. Das hat man ja im Prinzip schon, dass,
einfach so weltweites Schulter äh äh zucken so, ja okay, alles klar, die Amerikaner äh äh schnorcheln alles ab, die Briten auch. Äh was war jetzt nochmal,
Grad den News-Anteil hier, ja?
Das muss man einfach sehen, ja. Das ist einfach äh den meisten Leuten ziemlich äh egal. Nichtsdestotrotz wäre es schon äh wünschenswert, eine Debatte zu schüren, die eben grundsätzlich eben hinterfragt, ob diese Methoden nicht auch,
ähm Demokratie gefährdend sind,
einfach selbst mehr äh ins Bein schießen als uns jetzt irgendwelche Gefahren vom Hals zu halten. Das muss man einfach mal fokussieren dieser ganzen Aufregung, dass das eigentlich auch sagen wir mal der der Kernkritikpunkt ist,
an Überwachung an sich, meine äh ich denke auch große Teile,
eine aufgeklärten und überwachungskritischen,
Gesellschaft ist ja nicht gleich gegen Polizei oder gegen staatliche Exekutivgewalt an sich. Ja, ist ja nicht, dass man immer gleich Anarchie einfordert, sondern es geht ja einfach hier da drum, die Gewichtung,
Die ähm Kontrolle vor allem solcher Aktivitäten.
Ja das das stimmt,
Stimmt genau so, mir wird nur so als Randaspekt noch einfallen. Es geht nicht nur um das Verhältnis der,
Der Bürger und ihrer Staaten, sondern halt hier durch diese Auslandsgeheimdienstnummer, die ja das Einzige ist, was das überhaupt legitimiert, ja, also äh inlandsmäßig wär in jedem dieser Staaten diese Form der Überwachung nicht legal,
sondern eben auch auf das Verhältnis der Staaten untereinander.
Genau und da fällt mir ein, du hast einen Begriff auch noch gar nicht genannt äh in dem Zusammenhang, nämlich äh dieses Five Eyes Programm. Hast du gar nicht von gehört,
das war ja eine Aussage der Briten, dass diese Überwachungsmaßnahmen ja Teil der Five Eyes zusammenarbeit ist zwischen den USA, Britannien, Neuseeland, Australien und jetzt habe ich glatt vergessen, wer der fünfte war,
Ähm ich glaube noch mal,
befragen, dass äh äh Netz, aber an der Stelle wird es natürlich dann wieder sehr fragwürdig, weil.
Australien, Kanada, Neuseeland, UK und USA.
Ah okay, na liegt, ne. Also so ein so ein Angriff vieler Raum, der auch recht welt äh umspannend ist,
und wo dann jeder so steht und sagt so, nee, wir überwachen unsere Bürger nicht. Unsere Bürger überwachen die anderen vier,
Ja und die dürfen uns dann wieder alles geben. Also das ist natürlich auch ein Unterlaufen möglicher nationaler Gesetzgebung.
Ja, natürlich. Aber, also.
Nochmal benennen so, ne?
Daher kam ja auch der Snowden an diese äh an diese Informationen. Also da da da er hatte überhaupt einen äh Geheimdienst,
Äh Contractor aus den USA, die Information, was die Briten machen. Ähm.
Vielleicht grob wie Federn natürlich die Staaten diese Enthüllungen jetzt ab
Erstens ist es wunderbar, man kann äh diese diese Boulevardposse irgendwie abspielen, wo ist Edward Snowden? Das ist schon mal schön. Das reicht schon mal für Seite eins. Und falls jemand auf Seite zwei oder drei noch eine Frage stellt,
Ähm kannst hier in Ändern melden, dass Terroristen jetzt ihre Strategie ändern, ja? Damit ist also die Meldung raus, dass äh AdWords Snowden
Gefahr äh für die für die britische äh für die für die US-Amerikanische Bevölkerung gebracht hat. Ähm,
In Deutschland wir irgendwie ein paar ähm paar äh Moslems mit mit Modellflugzeugen verhaftet, weil sie angeblich einen Anschlag mit Modellflugzeugen geplant hätten,
Das war auch äh passt da auch wieder wie Arsch auf Eimer. Und man gibt dann einen sehr interessanten Artikel ähm,
wo gesagt wurde, okay, von äh Prison wurde enthüllt und danach gab es dann äh ein ein sehr starke Zunahme an Nutzung des der des der privat,
ja und dann wird das einfach mal ins Verhältnis gesetzt und dann sieht man also so zwei schöne Balken, da sieht man oh ähm hier.
Fünfzig Prozent Steigerung.
Fünfzig Prozent Steigerung an einem Tag, ja? Normalerweise zweitausend, jetzt dreitausend so ungefähr, ne? Also und.
Dann,
Also von sechzig auf neunzig Millionen oder so aber dann der Vergleich zu Google ist also ein Witz, ne? Da also Google hat da überhaupt nichts verloren, ja.
Ja, da haben die Hobbydatenschützer mal wieder den Aluhut aus dem Schrank geholt.
Also mal, ich denke sowieso, man muss da äh ich meine als ausm aus meiner,
Sicht als jemand, der sich sowieso viel mit IT äh Sicherheit auseinandersetzt, blicke ich da natürlich sowieso anders drauf und verhalte mich eh im Internet so als wäre da die ganze Zeit, dass die NSA äh auf dem Kabel,
und ähm.
Grußworte, beschwichtigende Formulierungen.
Großmutter sind Grußworte unter Grußworte unter äh NPGP Message irgendwie noch so Bombe, Bombo, Terror. Ähm.
Ja. Ich find's ja nun mal schön, dass man immer angezeigt bekommen würde, wer einen jetzt eigentlich gerade abhört, dass man sich auch entsprechend verhalten kann.
Also lass uns vielleicht, lass uns vielleicht diese diese gesellschaftliche Debatte jetzt gar nicht mehr aufmachen, also es ist sehr interessant, was da passiert und es ist vor allem.
Wenn man sich da ein bisschen drüber Gedanken macht, ist das so vorhersehbar, was da passiert, ne. Also dass jetzt hier wieder irgendwie irgendwelche
Kollegen mit Modellflugzeug verhaftet werden äh und am Ende, ne und dann gibt's die Obama hat ja auch schon irgendwie, ja, wir haben dank Prisum haben wir neunzig Terroristen
verhaftet die hundertachtzig Millionen Menschen töten wollten oder was auch immer, ne? Also es ist alles so
so absehbar, was da jetzt noch in Zukunft an Meldungen auf uns zukommt und ähm so einfach diesen Snowden.
Brochen einer albanisches Mädchen auf der Flucht.
Ja, weil also es ist so einfach jetzt den Snowden als äh als äh als wirklich als Verräter hinzustellen, ne? Und ähm das.
Wir werden sehen, was äh Eduardo noch so in der Tasche hat. Vielleicht äh hat er ja noch ein paar Überraschungen für uns.
Ja, wir werden sehen, ob sich da auf jeden, ob sich da überhaupt noch mal irgendwann jemand drüber aufregen wird.
Kommen wir von der Weltpolitik zu unseren schnöden Kleinkrämerei in äh Deutschland, wo die großen Probleme der Welt doch sehr fern erscheinen. Ähm es gibt Neues.
Ja, ab dem ersten August gilt.
Teilung Tokio so.
Aus der aus der Abteilung, also auch aus der Abteilung vorhersehbar, demnächst machen wir die die Logbuchfolgen schon vorher. Aus der Abteilung äh habe ich euch doch gesagt, ähm,
Ab ersten August gilt, glaube ich, dann das Leistungsschutzrecht. Auf jeden Fall möchte ab dann Google News doch gerne sicher gehen?
Dass alle, die auf Google News gelistet sind, damit auch einverstanden sind, das wäre ja schade,
Wenn ähm die Leute da nicht einverstanden werden auf Google News zu sein und äh das sind siebenhundert äh Webseiten jetzt gerade für registriert,
Für Google News und den hat Google jetzt gesagt, ja äh wir sind zwar ähm,
der an sich, dass äh Google News auch ohne Einwilligung äh nicht gegen irgendwelche Gesetze verstößt, auch nicht gegen dieses Neue.
Nur mal sicher zu gehen.
Aber wenn hier so eine Diskussion irgendwie stattfindet, dann wollen wir einfach mal kurz sicher gehen,
dass sie auch weiterhin an äh mit der Aufnahme ihrer Inhalte in Google News einverstanden sind, füllen sie doch bitte kurz hier dieses Formular aus und lassen sie uns das bis August zugehen. Wenn sie das nicht machen, respektieren wir ihren Wunsch natürlich.
Und nehmen sie raus.
Genau, also ob in wird auf einmal eingeschaltet und äh ich weiß nicht, hast du dieses Formular gesehen? Hast du gesehen, was da drauf steht?
Ich trete alle Rechte ab, ne ich hab das Formular nicht gesehen, weil.
Geht schon klar, die Aussage drin äh äh draus hervor mit äh wenn wir dich aufnehmen, dann zahlen wir nichts.
Ja klar, also ich habe das äh also gehe ich natürlich. Okay äh.
Naja, muss man auch mal benennen, so dass dass es darum sozusagen auch äh geht. Also es geht nicht nur darum, einverstanden zu sein, sondern es geht dadrum auch irgendwie klar zu machen, dass man eben keinerlei Royalties äh abführt.
Interessant ist, jetzt liegen also die Eier aufm Tisch und ähm ich bin mal gespannt, ob sich jetzt äh ob jetzt alle sagen, okay ähm,
Ja, natürlich wollen wir da drin sein und natürlich zahlen wir äh wollen wir da kein Geld für euch von haben? Dann äh hätten wir also klar, dass diese gesamte,
gesamte, ja, total, total für 'n Arsch war, diese gesamte Debatte, die müssen uns eigentlich die, die, das, was das gekostet hat, ja,
Müssen die Verlage uns alles zurückzahlen. Ähm wenn ich mache ich in meiner Steuererklärung anteilig geltend. Und ähm dann,
Wenn sie als nicht machen, dann bleibt ihnen ja nur der Weg irgendwie über äh Kartell zu kommen. Das hatte ich ja auch schon mal in einer der früheren Folgen.
Benannt, dass Google,
Man kann diesen Schritt von Google jetzt so interpretieren und ich bin mir sicher, dass das grade Anwälte prüfen, dass Google seine Marktvorherscherstellung dafür nutzt,
Menschen auf einen zu zwingen, auf ein Recht zu verzichten, das ihnen zusteht. Nämlich das Leistungsschutzrecht. Dass sie diese Sachen äh äh lizensiert haben können,
und dafür auch Geld bekommen können. Das heißt, äh entweder sind die Verlage ähm,
Schlau genug zu verstehen, dass das einfach ein dünnes dünne Planke ist, auf die sie da gerannt sind und dass dieser Christoph Käse halt vielleicht doch nicht so der richtige Berater war oder sie versuchen Google jetzt da ähm,
Zu kommen, wie wir äh Kartell- und Ausnutzen von Marktherrschaft. Wir werden es sehen.
Aber das sind die beiden Optionen, die sich jetzt bieten. Weil wenn du das mal, wenn man jetzt nur auf dem Gesetz nur mal auf dem Papier liest, die Verlage haben nun mal dieses Recht,
Und was Google da macht mit einer mit einer Grundklausel zu sagen, äh wir schließen aus, dass ihr von diesem Recht Gebrauch macht.
Ansonsten schließen wir euch aus von einer nachweislich wichtigen äh Seite
kann es da halt noch eine eine lange Diskussion geben. Und am Ende dieser Diskussion könnte Google entweder gezwungen werden, äh die mit aufzunehmen oder
das gesamte Leistungsschutzrecht könnte einfach mal wieder dahin zurückkommen, zurückgehen wo es herkommt.
Bin ich mal gespannt, da bin ich dann äh nicht Anwalt.
Das sind so die beiden.
Aber das sind so die beiden, die beiden Möglichkeiten, die sich jetzt in der Zukunft.
Also ist auf jeden Fall ist es absehbar, dass oder zeichnet sich auf jeden Fall ab oder war ja immer klar, dass Google auch einen sehr langen Hebel hat, ja, also hier wird auf beiden Seiten kräftig gehebelt und ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wo es enden wird.
Sie haben natürlich auch noch die, die Möglichkeit, ähm das wollen sie aber eventuell selber nicht, also,
ja auch noch sein kann, wenn die Verlage da jetzt irgendwie groß Trara machen, dass Google sagt, ach weißt du was?
Lösch mal bitte News Punkt Google DE, braucht man nicht, tut uns leid Deutschland.
Einfach abschalten, ne?
Habt ihr kein Google News, habt ihr keinen Streetview? Leckt uns an die Füße. Weißt du, so und das gönne ich mir halt auch sehr, sehr gut vorstellen, dass das noch passiert.
Weil es gibt ja auch sonst niemand, der dann in ihre äh Stiefel,
äh ihre, nein, nicht in ihre, in ihre Schuhabdrücke äh rein oder in ihre Stiefel rein, was ich bin halt ein bisschen Assoziationsbehindert. Auf jeden Fall niemand wird dann versuchen, einen alternativen Dienst aufzubauen, der letztlich mit derselben Bedrohung zu leben hat,
So, was haben wir noch?
Ja, Petitionsausschuss zur Netzneutralität hat stattgefunden. Johannes Scheller äh in den Tagesthemen, ja. Der junge Mann, der die äh Petition,
äh für die Netzneutralität da äh gestartet hat. Ähm saß dann da in diesem Petitionsausschuss. Das ging.
Zu Gast war, hier bei LOK Buchnetz Politik sechsundsechzig. Da warst du nicht dabei. Achso, er verstehe.
Da war ich aber nicht dabei, insofern erwähne ich das nicht. Genau, Johannes saß dann da, äh saß dann da im Petitionsausschuss und hat ähm hat er seine, sein Anliegen vorgetragen,
kann man sich wahrscheinlich auch nochmal anschauen.
Es gab dann, es wurde da viel diskutiert über diese Verordnung des Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums, das dann genau aber sagt, ja, für Internet wollen wir eben Best effert und ähm,
Wir sind gegen äh Privilegierung von bestimmten Inhalten und Anwendungen, aber,
Wir erlauben,
Inhaltsneutrale Qualitätsklassen, das sind dann eben äh Managed Services. Das heißt, letztendlich würden sie sagen,
Wenn ihr euer dürft's mit Spotify, Spezialvertrag machen, ihr dürftet nur nicht.
Direkt aus dem Internet kommen lassen, sondern ihr müsst es irgendwie über eine andere Qualitätsklasse äh technisch unterscheidbar von Internet an eure Kunden fließen lassen,
Genauso wie das bei ähm,
bei diesem Tier Home Entertaine eben der Fall ist, wo es eben wie Clemens ja auch schon erklärt hatte, nicht wirklich aus dem Internet kommt, sondern an der DSL äh Leitung irgendwie noch seit zeitlich mit dran geflanschtes Multi-Castes.
Das wäre also äh,
Ähm das wäre jetzt also dieser diese Verordnung des Bundes äh Wirtschaftsministeriums. Die müsste aber eh noch durch Bundestag und Bundesrat, das heißt, das wird in dieser Legislaturperiode sowieso nichts mehr ähm ist so ein,
Insgesamt so ein bisschen weiß ich nicht genau, einzuschätzen,
ich meine, wir haben Juli, im September ist Wahl.
Soll da jetzt noch groß passieren oder haben wir Juni, was haben wir überhaupt? Juni, ne? Ja, fast Julia. Ähm,
Aber okay, Anhörung war da. Äh,
Ich denke, äh ja, ich finde, er hat da seine Argumentation gut vorgetragen. Er hätte an einigen Stellen, dass wir jetzt so mein persönlicher Eindruck noch noch flammender für äh,
Äh Flammen dafür, äh für sein Anliegen werben können
Und ich bin ja auch äh ich da scheiden sich ja die Geister, ich bin ja durchaus dafür ähm auch eventuell eben ökonomisch
zu argumentieren im Rahmen der Wirtschaftsförderung, weil das ja etwas ist, worauf äh unsere Bundestagsabgeordneten sehr viel empfindlicher und sensibler reagieren, als wenn man ihnen einen von äh Freiheit erzählt,
aber insgesamt, das Ding hat also äh stattgefunden und wir haben auch mal verlinkt, diesen sagenumwogenen äh Bericht der Bundesnetzagentur, wo sie sagen, da sind noch viele Fragen offen, ja?
Und achso, die Verordnung,
Das war noch wichtig. Wir hatten ja diesen Paragrafen äh einundvierzig A, Telekommunikationsgesetz, wo er schon sagten, dass die Bundesregierung die Möglichkeit hat,
Netzneutralität irgendwie zu erzwingen, genau auf dem würde dann diese Verordnung fußen
Aber das ist eben dann eine Verordnung und nicht,
Gesetz, was grundsätzlich gilt. Und natürlich strebt äh Johannes absolut richtig, ein äh eine gesetzliche Regelung an.
Mit seiner Petition, ne? Steht ja auch, wir wollten Gesetze nicht, wir wollen eine wir wollen eine Verordnung vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium.
So, nächster Punkt.
Ja ähm.
Berichtet.
Da hatten wir schon zu berichtet, ähm ich wollte das nur, weil wir diese ganze Überwachungsgeschichte so schön,
ähm äh nochmal behandelt haben, auch weiterverfolgen. Die OECD-Beschwerde gegen Gamma, den Hersteller, die äh dieser Spähsoftware ähm,
wurde also angenommen, ja? Das waren äh Privacy International Reporter ohne Grenzen, äh
sowie bei reinwatch hatten ja damals diese OECD-Beschwerde gegen Trophychor und Gamma angestrengt und ähm,
Die Briten haben jetzt gesagt, ja, also äh wir werden eine äh Prüfung vornehmen, die werden wir veröffentlichen und.
Politik vierundfünfzig im Februar.
Also genau, das, da haben wir uns ja relativ viel mit auseinandergesetzt. Die Spähsoftware äh,
die da in Bahein äh eingesetzt wurde und die von dem deutschen ähm,
Martin Münch als Geschäftsführer eines,
undurchsichtigen Konglomerats an Briefkastenfirmen irgendwie in alle Welt vertrieben wird.
Haben wir viel drüber gesprochen. Jetzt äh kümmert sich mal die OECD da drum,
Gleichzeitig äh ist auch nichts Neues, nur jetzt gibt's da noch mal wirklich einen Beleg für das Innenministerium hat den der guten Firma Gamma jetzt erstmal schon mal knapp hundertfünfzigtausend Euro
hingeschrieben um hingeschrieben um diese Software die ganz klar nach deutschen Rechtsstaatsprinzipien nicht einsetzt eingesetzt werden darf,
weil sie um einiges äh umfangreicher und,
schlimmer und bösartiger ist als das, was wir was wir überhaupt hatten als als deutschen Staatstrojaner. Trotzdem,
hat das äh äh BKA da jetzt eine äh eine Zusammenarbeit äh über zwölf Monate äh vereinbart um eine äh Softwarelizenz äh,
zu haben und um damit irgendwie Leute zu schulen und wann nicht alles, ne? Also sie prüfen diese Software nach wie vor,
Es ist ganz klar, dass das gegen alles äh gegen jedes Gesetz in Deutschland verstößt, viel zu umfangreiche äh Penetration des Zielsystems und ähm da findet aber keinen daran,
Die hundertfünfzigtausend auszugeben. Es gab ja da auch schon die Beschwerde beim Bundesrechnungshof, die von der Piratenpartei angestrengt wurde.
Ja, das macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob solange geprüft werden soll, bis sich da keiner mehr dafür interessiert, was das Ergebnis dieser Prüfung ist und dann wird's halt einfach benutzt. Könnte allerdings noch eine Weile dauern.
Jo
So sieht es aus. Vielleicht eine kurze,
Ich wollte das eventuell erst dann in der nächsten äh Woche wirklich behandeln, aber kurz als Aussicht. Äh es gibt einen Verhandlungstermin für das ähm,
Verfahren, dass ihr Land und die und Österreich gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh
Na, jetzt, jetzt habe ich's ja eher, ich erzähle das noch kurz. Ähm,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung. EU-Richtlinie kam, Deutschland setzte das um und äh Karlsruhe sagte, die Ausgestaltung dieser Richtlinie, wie Deutschland, das hier momentan macht, ist
Verfassungsrecht äh verfassungswidrig. Karlsruhe hat aber nicht zu der Richtlinie selber gesagt. Mhm. In äh
als Resultat kam dann irgendwann dieses Klageverfahren der EU-Kommission gegen Deutschland wegen der Nichtumsetzung. Wir erinnern uns, dass es immer diese
böse äh äh die böse Strafe, die die äh Unionspolitiker zitieren, wenn sie äh Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger dafür kritisieren, dass wir noch keine Vorratsdaten spe.
So ein paar tausend Euro pro Tag irgendwie fertig sind bei nicht Umsetzung, was so.
Acht Cent oder soweit am Tag pro Bürger oder so, normal ausgerechnet. Ne, ähm,
Also Deutschland hat sich entschieden, okay, wir wir machen's erstmal nicht, äh halten die Füße still und und äh warten, bis die EU-Kommission uns verklagt und versuchen, dass dadurch dann wieder reinzudrücken,
Österreich und Irland,
haben aber gegen die äh äh gegen die Richtlinie, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
verlangt am ähm,
Europäischen Gerichtshof geklagt und dort in Luxemburg findet jetzt äh dann die Verhandlung statt am neunten Juli oder beginnt.
Österreich von Anfang an mit dabei, ging das nicht ursprünglich von Irland.
Das ging von Irland aus und weil wie es in Österreich war, das hatte uns äh Thomas sehr viel später auch schon mal hier in einer Folge Logbuch Netzpolitik erzählt, die ich auch schon verlinkt habe in den Shownotes,
Ja, aber genau über die über genau über die Klagen von Österreich und Irland wird jetzt dann am,
EuGH verhandelt werden in Luxemburg und die beziehen sich auf zwei Grundrechte nach der EU-Charta,
Nämlich erstens die äh Achtung der Kommunikation und den Schutz personenbezogener Daten. Diese Charter trat aber irgendwie erst später in Kraft,
Und äh das Spannende ist jetzt, dass jetzt die Richter, deswegen wird das jetzt schon zur Meldung, ähm so ihre die Fragen,
veröffentlicht haben oder rausgeschickt haben, die sie gerne beantwortet hätten. Für ihre Entscheidung,
Und da sagen sie so, ja, in welchem Umfang ist denn Profilerstellung möglich? Also Persönlichkeit, Umfeld berufliche Tätigkeit, wenn ich sechs Monate die kompletten Kommunikationsbewegungen einer Person ähm aufzeichne, ja, das wollen sie gerne mal wissen.
Ja, interessante Frage.
Und das ist natürlich enorm, ja? Es ist enorme Profilerstellung, aber okay, die Frage. Dann sagen sie, ja wie kommen wir denn eigentlich darauf, dass das laut Richtlinie mindestens sechs Monate sein müssen? Wieso nicht drei? Wieso nicht zwei? Wieso nicht einer? Wieso nicht zwölf? Ja?
Und ähm,
Dann würden sie ganz gerne mal Statistiken sehen, dass irgendwie die äh sich bei der Verfolgung schwerer Straftaten irgendwie was verbessert hätte. Diese Statistiken gibt's nicht. Die müssen jetzt noch schnell,
neu zusammengekratzt werden,
Und dann würde sie auch noch interessieren, wie denn so der Missbrauch verhindert wird bei dem Ansatz, den wir da fahren.
Mhm.
Und es wird jetzt so, deswegen, wie gesagt, ist das Ganze so schon zur Meldung geworden, äh, gefeiert, dass die Richter immerhin schon mal diese kritischen Fragen stellen
wo die äh Befürworter einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung ähm sich sehr viel Mühe geben,
werden, geben müssen, werden, geben werden müssen.
Geben werden müssen,
werden.
Irgendwas mit Mühe wissen schon, äh um da irgendwie mal eine eine Antwort äh zu liefern
die äh ja auch nur halbwegs befriedigend ist, ja? Es kann sein, dass du dir die ganze Zeit äh unter Verschluss halten, diese Antworten, während die Vorzeichensprechung überall auf der Welt,
diskutiert wird, weil sie sie erst dann bei diesem schönen Verfahren auch wirklich äh aus der Tasche holen wollen,
meine Einschätzung ist, dass ich ihn da relativ schwer fallen wird. Darauf befriedigende Antworten,
zu finden, die diesen massiven Grundrechtseingriff.
Fertigen. Ich freue mich vor allem, wie sie das mit den Statistiken hinbekommen wollen, was sie sich da aus der Nase ziehen, um da irgendwie die Sache zu belegen.
Das wird schwierig,
Aber nichts Genaues wissen wir nicht, wollen wir aber nicht zu früh feiern. Äh es gibt eben erste Anhaltspunkte, dass da eventuell äh sich Richter mit dieser Klage befassen, die,
sich da auch mal ausführlich mit befassen wollen. Das wäre dann mal eine feine Sache.
Gut, damit kommen wir dann hier äh zum Ende. Man merkt wieder, wir haben schon wieder nicht die den Takt eingehalten und schon muss man wieder ein bisschen nachlegen. Thematisch.
Ja, so ist das. Ähm ja, mir fällt jetzt auch nicht mehr viel ein. Gibt's sonst noch irgendwas, worauf wir noch hinweisen müssten äh.
Heute Abend gibt's ein Chaos-Radio zu zu der.
Da bist du mal wieder dabei, ne?
Temporahr und den großen Brüdern und anderen großen Brüdern,
Da bin ich zusammen mit dem Andy Müller-Margun und dem Erdgeist und dem Markus Richter und äh.
Radio hunderteinundneunzig wird das dann sein, genau.
Bin mal gespannt, was wir da äh noch so erzählen können. Also so den technischen Aspekt habe ich jetzt hier noch ein bisschen unterbeleuchtet gelassen. Eventuell fallen uns da noch mehr Sachen ein, die wir erzählen können.
Ja, ansonsten gibt's jetzt gerade irgendwie keine großen Termine auf den Ball, glaube ich, unbedingt hinweisen müssten.
Nicht im Podcast. Also ich habe viele Termine, aber achso, eine Sign findet statt. Ich weiß nicht, gehst du dieses Jahr hin?
Ich werde genau richtig. Das war's. Ähm fünften bis siebten Juli in Köln,
Äh ich habe jetzt nicht unbedingt Daueranwesenheit geplant, aber ich werde eh in der Region sein und sicherlich da auch mal vorbeischauen, weiß aber noch nicht so genau, wann und äh wie. Ähm ja.
Geht mir genauso. Ich bin äh ich werde dort vorbeischauen, vermutlich am Samstag,
Weiß ich auch noch nicht so genau. Vielleicht auch schon Freitagabend, aber ich komme auch mal vorbei, beide Seekind. Eine Veranstaltung des Chaoscomputerclubs,
Wie heißt das Ding nochmal, Komedia Park oder sowas?
Komet im MediaPark Köln. Komet heißt dieser Konferenzlocation, äh die da Teil des Mediaparks ist und das ist halt da, wo so der Mediapark ist.
Am Mediapark ist eine Veranstaltung des.
Genau, das gibt's auch schon seit einigen Jahren und da gibt's dann immer wieder auch netzpolitisch relevante Talks, auch wenn ich jetzt grade auf nichts verweisen kann, was ich zugeben muss, dass ich das Programm noch nicht so ernsthaft äh studiert habe, ne.
Habe ich auch noch nicht.
Genau. Jo.
Immer, ist sowieso immer eine Empfehlung, ne, Veranstaltungen sind immer eine Empfehlung.
Genau, Leute treffen, Spaß haben. Gut, Guiness, das war's. Wir sagen tschüss.
Ja, ja, tschüss. Tschüss.